Siempre es bueno ver las distintas soluciones
que se le pueden dar a un problema,
en particular estos problemas de razones
admiten distintas soluciones,
dependiendo de la persona que las desarrolla.
En el video que hicimos de este problema,
planteamos que un principio la razón de manzanas
a naranjas era de 5 a 8 y que cuando
eliminábamos 15 manzanas,
esa razón se hacía de 1 a 4
y respondimos a la pregunta,
¿cuántas frutas en total tengo después
de eliminar 15 manzanas?
Resolvimos el problema y encontramos que nos
quedaban 50 piezas de fruta,
la solución la encontramos platicando,
planteamos nuestra consideraciones de manera verba.
Veamos si podemos resolverlo
de una manera más algebraica.
Así es que hagamos "m" el número de manzanas
al inicio, las manzanas que teníamos inicialmente
y "n", el número de naranjas que no cambia,
"n" el número de naranjas.
Así es que la razón de "m" a "n",
la razón de manzanas a naranjas...
la razón de "m" a "n", esto es igual a...
me parece que voy a necesitar más espacio
para no amontonarme en este pequeño pedazo...
así es que voy a copiar esto, marcamos,
copiamos y esto lo vamos a pegar acá abajo...
vamos a pegarlo aquí abajo para tener más
espacio, listo, ahí lo tenemos.
Quedamos entonces que "m" es el número de
manzanas al inicio y "n" es el número de naranjas.
Y la relación de "m" a "n" es...
voy a escribirla en un color que no haya usado,
en blanco que no lo he usado...
así es que la relación de "m" a "n" es de 5 a 8,
eso es lo que nos dicen,
que si en un inicio se divide el número de manzanas
entre el número de naranjas,
se establece una relación de 5 a 8.
Su razón para ser más precisos,
es de 5 a 8.
Cuando quitamos 15 manzanas,
nos quedan "m" menos 15 manzanas
y nos dicen que entonces
la razón de manzanas a naranjas es de 1 a 4,
así es que "a" menos 15, el número de manzanas
que tenemos cuando quitamos 15,
la razón de eso al número de naranjas
resulta entonces de 1 a 4.
Veamos si podemos resolver este sistema,
tenemos ahora un sistema
de 2 ecuaciones con 2 incógnitas,
el número de manzanas "m" y el número de
naranjas "n", se parecen un poco las letras,
podríamos confundirnos, pero no, voy a hacerlo
con cuidado para que no nos pase eso.
Déjame volver a escribir aquí abajo
el sistema de ecuaciones.
La razón original de manzanas a naranjas
es de 5 a 8 y cuando eliminamos 15 manzanas,
la nueva razón
de manzanas a naranjas es de 1 a 4,
ésta es una manera algebraica
de plantear nuestro problema.
En la ecuación del lado izquierdo hagamos
la multiplicación cruzada de los denominadores.
Obtenemos entonces "8m" es igual a "5n" y
si restamos "5n" a ambos lados, nos queda
del lado izquierdo
"8m" menos "5n" es igual a 0,
ésta es simplemente una ecuación lineal
con dos incógnitas.
¿Qué obtenemos en la ecuación del lado derecho?
De nueva cuenta hacemos la multiplicación
cruzada de los denominadores para obtener,
"4m" menos 60, he hecho la multiplicación
de 4 por 15, es igual a 1 por "n", "n",
lo voy a dejar como "1n".
¿Ahora qué hacemos?
Vamos a restar "1n" a ambos lados y nos queda,
"4m" menos "1n" menos 60 igual a 0,
sumamos ahora 60 a ambos lados
y obtenemos "4m" menos "1n" es igual a 60.
Y aquí se ve claramente que tenemos un sistema
de dos ecuaciones lineales, aquí tenemos una
y aquí tenemos la otra ecuación,
con dos incógnitas, "m" y "n".
Podía haber usado "x" y "y" para asignar
las variables y así no confundiría esta
"n" con la "m", en fin, si tenemos cuidado
con eso no hay ningún problema.
¿Y cómo resolvemos esto?
Podemos multiplicar una de las ecuaciones
por un factor adecuado para posteriormente,
al sumar o restar las ecuaciones,
se elimine una de las variables.
Hagamos eso.
Multiplicando la primera ecuación por -2,
obtenemos, "-8m" más "2n" es igual a -120,
esta ecuación la obtuvimos al multiplicar
la ecuación de arriba por -2.
Sumemos ahora la ecuación que tenemos aquí,
es decir, vamos a sumar "8m" menos "5n"
que es igual a 0, hacemos la suma,
"-8m" más "8m" es igual a 0,
"2n" menos "5n" resulta en "-3n",
lo cual es igual a -120.
Esto equivale a "n" igual a,
dividiendo entre -3 ambos lados de la ecuación,
se obtiene que "n" igual a 40...
"n" igual a 40.
Ese es el número de naranjas...
naranjas igual a 40.
Es un valor que no cambia, es el mismo al
inicio y al final, "n" igual a 40.
Ahora para encontrar el número de manzanas,
podemos recurrir a cualquiera de estas ecuaciones,
ésta es la que se ve más simple.
"8m" es igual a "5n",
8 por "m" es igual a 5 por el número de naranjas,
5 por "n", es decir, 5 por 40...
5 por 40, 8 por "a" es igual a 200,
dividiendo entre 8 ambos lados,
"a" es igual a 200 sobre 8,
lo cual se simplifica como 100 sobre 4,
para obtener que "m" es igual a 25.
Recordemos lo que es "m" y "n".
"n" es el número de naranjas
que tenemos durante todo el problema,
"m" es el número de manzanas
con las que empezamos,
esto es al inicio...
al inicio.
Hemos encontrado que al inicio teníamos
25 manzanas y 40 naranjas,
es decir, iniciamos con 40 y 25, 65 piezas de fruta,
65 frutas y al eliminar 15 frutas,
al final teníamos 50 frutas.
La cual es exactamente la misma
respuesta que obtuvimos
cuando hicimos el problema por primera vez.
Que bueno que lo hicimos de dos maneras,
si deseas saber el número de manzanas al final,
al inicio había 25 manzanas, se eliminaron 15,
con lo cual quedan 10 manzanas.
Empezamos con 25 manzanas,
40 naranjas, 65 frutas
y terminamos con 10 manzanas,
40 naranjas, en total, 50 frutas.
En fin, espero que te haya sido útil haber
resuelto este problema de una manera diferente.